good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is welcome
obstacles over to you louis c.k one
finds oneself you know some resistance
an obstacle is always good for art I
think so it's like if you have a marble
you know Michelangelo has this big block
of marble and he needs to dig David out
of there right not only does he need to
did you know chip away just the right
amount of marble but he has to then you
know find this thing in there and then
he has to smooth that out make it
perfect right if they if David had if
Michelangelo was given a marble it just
comes away really what did he have been
better sculptor you don't I mean there's
something about the having to navigate
the actual physical work of it or like
mental and emotional work yeah and just
being like I don't think I can do this I
think it's a great push for an artist
this is gonna be impossible when you
think about some a lot of the greatest
movies were made very much in the studio
system and they were made by people who
were faced with all kinds of fear and
myopia from their studios and they led
them out of it they had I think
sometimes they can sharpen your vision
when you have to convince people so one
of the most consistent messages that
comes up on this channel is are they
studies successful people is that
whatever happens in life whatever
happens in your business that it serves
you like good or bad whatever is
happening you find a way to make it
serve you to grow stronger to be better
to have a better life to build a better
business and that's easy when it's good
right it's easy when you land the big
sale is easy when you get that huge
opportunity it's easy when that big
break finally comes through
to feel good about that easy to see how
that serves you it's a lot harder when
it's the negative when is an obstacle
where there's a problem to see how does
this serve me right like I just lost a
big client how does that serve me right
I just lost tons of subscribers how does
that serve me timo just chewed up my
slipper or I'm stuck in traffic how does
that serve me and I think being able to
just flip the question whenever you're
feeling frustrated whenever you're
feeling overwhelmed whenever you feel
like complaining switching it to ask
yourself how does it serve me you
immediately switch from a place of being
feeling hopeless of having no resources
to move into a place of being resources
to saying this is gonna help me how does
being stuck in traffic serve me well
it's a chance to practice my patience
I'm growing in my patience I'm
practicing really hard and my patience
right and it's not that I want to be in
traffic it's not like I'm gonna
forcefully put myself in traffic just to
practice my patience although that might
be an interesting experiment if I can't
change it right I'm stuck in this
traffic I have to go in the future yes I
can adjust it I can plan my routine
maybe I won't take that road the next
time maybe I'd look up online if there's
any traffic delays maybe I won't take
the car anymore at all you know future I
can adjust but in the moment right now I
can't do anything about it so instead of
being negative instead of complaining
instead of feeling hopeless instead of
blaming everybody else to just ask how
does it serve me what can I learn from
this how can I grow from this how can it
make me more patient stronger better as
a human being as an entrepreneur I think
just in general successful people do
that to various degrees they don't get
stuck in the crap in the moment in the
complaints and somebody else's problem
in this getting stuck in the mud they
find any situation and they look at a
way to help it build themselves forward
or if you look at every successful
person like people that you look up to
people who are self-made people they
overcame insane obstacles like they
overcame more obstacles than you're
facing right now the biggest problem
that you have in your life is nothing
compared to the things that these people
overcame and they had to have the belief
that they could overcome it and they had
to have the belief that those problems
served
right that all the crap that was thrown
on top of them allowed them to be
stronger allowed them to grow that
struggle gave them strength and so one
of the things that I've tried to do for
myself is any time I find myself
complaining or upset or frustrated
doesn't happen that often I'm generally
pretty positive and optimistic but it
happens I'm not perfect you know I hate
being in traffic it's still a trigger
for me I was in traffic today and and I
thought you know it caught myself right
how does it serve me I get to practice
my patience think good the branches of
my patient right and so one trying to
catch yourself when it happens and to
letting the people around you know like
hey if you ever see me upset you ever
see me frustrated you ever see me angry
I want you to remind me I want you to
remind me I want you to show me a mirror
right and say this is your obstacle this
is your chance to grow and ask yourself
how does it serve me so the question of
day today is I'm curious what is a major
obstacle that you had to overcome and
that made you a stronger person that
made you a better entrepreneur a better
human being
you grew from it what was that obstacle
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Christian
Hirschfeld from Hirschfeld net thank you
so much Christian for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events press o
this presto keep me go
difficult to tell some of these stories
that you want to tell in the allotted
time you're given I'm using here boom
there we go there's always a thing or
two that falls out you know that you're
excited about that you know how you
really wish this point or joke or
whatever could make it in but what 21:50
whatever the amount that we get is 25
something small but we I'm happy with
it's a fun obstacle trying right around
that trying to capture everything that
you want to say myself you make a
business decision or a choice and it
turns out to be a mistake you were
totally wrong you can you can see that
as a mistake and you can get down on
yourself where you can see it as a
chance to get comfortable with failure
because failure is a part of life where
a scientist doesn't get upset when a
hypothesis that they had turns out to be
wrong because it that's what they do
that's the whole point they they're
learning each time they do something
wrong or a computer I'm sure as college
students a lot of you get this as well
you're you spend weeks and weeks working
on a paper and the computer deletes it
right a glitch erases the work that
you've had so you can get upset you can
do it when I did the last time this
happened to me it was you get so upset
then you kick a trash can across the
room and it makes a huge dent in the
wall or you can see this as a chance to
to start over you can see is a chance to
now that you've been through it once to
do it again and ultimately produce a
piece of work that's of higher quality
than maybe you originally intended to to
turn it you can you can use it the
chance to actually raise your standard
rather than then simply model through
try to think about that quote what's
what's the impediment to action advances
action what stands in the way becomes
the way I try to think about this in my
own life
whenever I'm facing any kind of
situation and I've yet to find one that
is it made better from this attitude
that isn't made better by seeing each
and every obstacle as a chance to
practice excellence and it's and it's in
a new form
and you know I came today we all face
our own problems there's tough economic
times we have a political situation
that's a you know we all face individual
obstacles as a daily basis and we
culturally face obstacles but we have a
chance to see those things like vase on
them which is to not only not see them
as bad but to see them as as
opportunities as as chances to improve
or to practice something that perhaps we
we otherwise wouldn't have practiced but
if you see the football players when
they win a big title Champions League
for example a lot of them they fall to
the ground yeah it's just that there's
so so many emotions going through your
mind through your body undoubtedly there
is a huge pressure and expectations and
and the importance of that moment and
you're aware of that you know you can't
put it aside and say okay I'm gonna
ignore it no it becomes a part of you it
consumes you now it's it's it's on you
if you if you are able to if you are
able to overcome that obstacle to face
that I would say big sensation of mix of
doubts fears excitement you know
pressure or so forth and if you are able
to become one with it and then then it
allows you to get to where you want to
be if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple
that would be kind of like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details